[Musica]
costo di appena comunicato entrando in
questo modo probabilmente vi ho
trasmesso in sicurezza tensione
difficoltà di approccio addirittura
bassa autostima
eppure non ho proferito parola o meglio
è stato il corpo a parlare per me e voi
quanto ritenete che linguaggio corporeo
possa avere un ruolo fondamentale
nell'interazione con voi stessi e con
gli altri
il corpo è il nostro principale
strumento di comunicazione che a
differenza della mente che mente
spudoratamente ci invia messaggi
autentici
il fatto è che noi non sappiamo
interpretarle ancor peggio quando anche
siamo in grado di farlo guarda un po lo
riprendiamo in considerazione
eppure il corpo ci parla parla a noi
parla le persone che sono intorno a noi
e lo fa con l'atteggiamento posturale
con la mimica con la gestualità
addirittura con i silenzi cioè lo fa con
tutta quella che si definisce
comunicazione non verbale che distingue
il cosa si dice dalle come viene detto e
arriva prima delle parole quelle stesse
parole che talvolta non sono credibili
non fosse altro perché dissonanti da ciò
che il corpo se esprimendo per essere
allineati beh è necessaria coerenza
piena coerenza tra il cosa si dice il
come viene detto tra l'intenzione è
l'identità tra il pensiero e l'azione
le azioni sono l'espressione motoria dei
nostri pensieri
durando un brainstorming aziendale può
capitare che qualcuno di punto in bianco
si alzi dalla sedia e urli l'ho trovata
ha trovato la strategia ha trovato
quella soluzione che si cercava e guarda
caso comincia a muoversi quasi in
procinto di voler afferrare pur di
renderla trasformarla il risultato il
corpo è la risorsa immediatamente
disponibile dalla quale noi possiamo
attingere tutte le volte che vogliamo è
un vero e proprio biglietto da visita e
come tale va rispettato
va preservato va valorizzato
è un veicolo che promozionare gli altri
attraverso i movimenti attraverso il
suono delle parole attraverso gli
sguardi addirittura attraverso gli odori
agire positivamente sul corpo significa
assumere abitudini corrette significa
entrare in ascolto con noi stessi con
quell essenza profonda con quell'armonia
che ci rende unici e distinguibili
chi di voi non conosce la locuzione
latina mens sana in corpore sano
la rinomata sentenza tratta da un verso
del poeta giovenale che guarda caso
evoca immagini di benessere mentale
connesso ad un corpo efficiente in piena
salute
per me ha rappresentato o ancor meglio
mi accompagna da sempre sia nella vita
personale che professionale tanto da
diventare la matrice dei miei pensieri
quotidiani tanto da trasformarla in
manager sana in corpore sano e si ha
rappresentato quella leva verso quella
motivazione che mi ha spinto ad agire
anche nei momenti più difficili anche
quando a 30 anni
del piero della mia attività di
imprenditore sportivo ed istruttore di
ginnastica dopo l'incidente stradale
mi sono sentito risucchiare in una
gabbia con le ali tarpate
ma senza vie d'uscita
oltre la sofferenza fisica che provavo
mi resi conto fin da subito che abbiamo
perso quello stato totale di armonia
in pratica avevo perso l'equilibrio che
si interpone tra
pensieri ed emozioni tra emozioni ed
azioni
disattendendo tutti i verbali medici
decisi di reagire pur di dare un
significato a quell'evento estremamente
traumatico ma ancor più di non subirlo
ulteriormente cominciai a lavorare per
immagini visualizzandone in una realtà
completamente nuova diversa da quella
che stavo vivendo ogni singolo pensiero
ogni cellula del mio corpo era
indirizzata verso quel nuovo paradigma
verso quel cambiamento consapevole
fu allora che comprese che la ricerca
del nostro equilibrio passa attraverso
il movimento albert einstein sosteneva
che la vita è come andare in bicicletta
se vuoi restare in equilibrio è già devi
muoverti e quando questo movimento è
consapevole e fortemente voluto e
desiderato che corpo mente e spirito
si uniscono all universo intero
ora per andare controverso a tutti tutti
poi tutti i presenti vi invito di
sfidare i vostri limiti di andare oltre
i vostri limiti limiti si che sono
impressi solo nella vostra mente per cui
alzatevi in piedi postati tutto ciò che
avete tutto
prendete gli spazi che avete a
disposizione toccatevi tra di voi
lasciatevi andare grazie tutti tutti
anche gli spalti tutti per piacere un
momento unico rendilo indelebile
concentratevi su di voi sono qui mi
piace tanto che vi siete alzati
lasciatevi andare rendiamo questo
momento unico unico
e seguimento seguimi seguì mese qui mi
voglio vedere le tue braccia mi piace
tantissimo lasciano andare giù questo è
quello che io cerco creare un unico
corpo che vola le braccia saranno
sostituite dalle ali e allora inspira
con me e spira inspira lascia le braccia
qui adesso puntale verso l'alto le tue
mani sono qua facciamo vedere a san
patrignano che noi siamo con san
patrignano che noi siamo tra di noi che
noi siamo una comunità intera muoviamo
nelle braccia muoviamo le mani scusami
nuovi le movide e ora fa che questo sia
possibile perché il tuo momento
inspira seguimento
spiega questa gambetta qui la tua destra
bra voglio vedere tutto il movimento
fletti il braccio vieni qui con me porta
questo abbraccio a te immagina che in
questa mano adesso c'è la risorsa
migliore che cerchi
lascia che passi per il tuo cuore
inspira purifica la fermati qua non è
altro che una condivisione per cui ora
che ruoti la mano guarda chi è accanto a
te e dona dona inspira torna con me
sapete piegare anche la sinistra certo
freddo il braccio è un'altra risorsa che
ti puoi giocare può essere la felicità
la serie vita l'amore può essere tutto
ciò che stai cercando e che non trovi in
questo momento lo stai condividendo con
più di mille persone
passa per il tuo cuore la e purificata
donal a sei con me e qui centrato quando
è difficile abbracciare gli altri
effettivamente lo sentiamo dire da
stamattina un abbraccio io abbraccio di
tua braccini e poi l'abbraccio guarda un
po ciao ciao tutto bene tutto ok io ci
sono 36 hanno nè rimini wellness no
[Applauso]
[Musica]
il mio compito non è finito ancora spero
che è il momento di volare
lasciatevi andare ancora come portale
braccia in alto come prima che mi piace
tantissimo
guarda la tua destra toccherà il cielo
quindi fa in modo tale che la destra
tocca il seno
eccola la la sinistra potrebbe fare lo
stesso magari alternando perfetto ora ti
chiedo l'impossibile è già si dovesse
provare ad aprire le gambe come me
perché c'è una cosa unica che lascerà il
segno del cielo di sanpa sai con me
unisci le mani qua qui dentro c'è la tua
energia qui dentro c'è la sua
spiritualità qui dentro c'è quella
risorsa che cerchi e dai
non mi fate ridere sono una persona
serissima ragazzino io scherzo quando
scherzo scherzo seriamente per cui
scherziamo eccola qua e con acqua con la
quale ho trovata far scendere le tue
mani né un po sotto la cintura guarda
cosa faccio io voglio vedere dopo voi su
questo attrezzino qua eh
eccola la mano destra si stacca si
stacca o un arco in mano e non devo fare
altro che tirare una freccia nel cielo è
questo quello che io voglio lascia il
segno a sanpa lascialo eccomi mica
possiamo farlo sul gommato
no sarebbe troppo bello eccomi eccomi
eccomi eccomi eccomi la rincorsa ragazzo
ora lascia un segno che sia indelebile
l'avevo detto che c'era una cosa
difficile da fare avete letto la poesia
ora il momento di volare
sapete quando siamo proprio in grado di
poterci dire io sto volando si dà solo
voli voli dei tuoi sogni i tuoi sogni si
realizzano ma si realizzano grazie alle
persone che sono intorno a te grazie le
persone che a me
e allora il primo diretto vicino vostro
senza guardarlo negli occhi abbraccia
forte alessandro carrozzo puoi salire
che ho bisogno di abbracciarti
abbracciatevi ma bene fortemente ma
matteo christian braccio forte deve
essere continuo come questo proprio come
questo resta lì resta lì abbracciato
[Musica]
[Applauso]
io non l'ho detto
ma mi chiamo gennaro setola vengo da
lontano
ma vi porto nel cuore
[Applauso]
no
[Musica]
[Applauso]